according to U.S Department of Labor
Bureau the computer and Information
Technology field is expected to grow by
13 percent from 2016 to 2026 faster than
the average dual trade of all the
occupations by 2026 another 557
000 jobs are expected to be added within
the field sounds fascinating right here
is another very important statistic for
you to know PWC says that by 2030 the
talent shortage and skills Gap in the
United States alone is expected to incur
a total loss of 8.5 trillion dollars and
this digital skills Gap comes at a cost
14 G20 countries could miss out on 11.5
trillion cumulative GDP growth according
to R A N D and Salesforce it is
profoundly evident that there is a huge
demand and Supply Gap in the present day
IT industry so if you wish to make your
career in the IT industry there is no
better time than now
You Must Be Wondering though how to
venture into the I.T sector and what are
the best ways to learn those skills that
can land your dream job well you have
come to the right place with that said
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
where we discuss everything Tech
upskilling and jobs make sure to
subscribe to get regular updates from us
in this video we will discuss five
computer courses that anybody can pursue
after graduation in order to make a nice
and secure future but before we begin
let me ask you a quick question so which
of the following computer courses
focuses on designing and building
websites option A is computer networking
option b is database management option C
is software development and option D is
web development now you can pause this
video and answer in the comment section
below alright now starting with the
first course that we can pursue after
graduation so the first course is post
graduate program in cyber security by
simply learn the postgraduate program in
cyber security is an intensive course
designed to provide you with the
necessary skills and expertise to excel
in the rapidly expanding field of cyber
security with the ever increasing threat
landscape it is crucial for
professionals to stay updated on the
latest trends and Technologies in order
to effectively protect their
organizations from cyber attacks this
program is specially tailored to help
you achieve that in this program you
will learn how to protect your computer
systems and sensitive information from
hackers and other threats you will learn
about analyzing risk coming up with the
ways to reduce those risks and following
rules and regulations to keep everything
secure by understanding how cyber
security works you will be able to put
strong measures in place to protect
against cyber threats one of the
exciting parts of this program is that
it includes stock notes cyber security
certification courses these
certifications are highly respected in
the industry and will give you the
recognition and credibility to succeed
in your career you will also have the
chance to learn from experts at the
prestigious Massachusetts Institute of
Technology that is MIT through special
classes this will enhance your learning
and give you valuable insights from
readers in the field now moving on to
the next field which is post graduate
program in digital marketing this
postgraduate program from Purdue
University is a comprehensive program
designed to equip you with the essential
skills and knowledge needed to excel in
the dynamic field of digital marketing
this course offers a unique blend of
Life interaction learning practical
projects Cutting Edge AI tools and real
world case studies from Harvard Business
publishing with a focus on website
creation and promotion this course takes
Hands-On approach to teaching digital
marketing techniques you will learn how
to build your own website and Implement
effective strategies to attract and
engage your target audience through live
interaction sessions led by experienced
Purdue faculty you'll gain a deep
understanding of both fundamental and
advanced digital marketing concepts
preparing you for successful career in
this rapidly evolving industry one of
the standout features of this
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the integration of chat GPT
and AI tools these powerful resources
allow you to harness the capabilities of
AI enabling you to optimize your digital
marketing efforts and stay ahead of the
competition now coming to our next
course which is post graduate program in
data analytics the data analytics
program offered in partnership with
Purdue University and in collaboration
with IBM is an excellent opportunity to
boost your career in the field of data
analytics this program stands out in
providing master classes and employing
an applied learning model that focuses
on real life projects and business case
studies one of the key advantages of
this program is its suitability for all
working professionals irrespective of
their programming background and even if
you lack prior programming knowledge you
can still enroll and benefit from this
course
it is designed to cater to individuals
from various professional backgrounds
who are interested in enhancing their
skills in data analytics the program
covers a wide range of essential topics
including data analysis data
visualization regression techniques and
supervised learning through the applied
learning model you will have the
opportunity to gain in-depth knowledge
and practical experience in these areas
the curriculum is crafted to ensure you
understand the concepts thoroughly and
can apply them to real-world scenarios
next up we have is professional
certificate course in data science by
simply learn the course is designed to
make learning data science easy and
practical you will have access to live
classes led by industry experts as well
as pre-recorded videos that you can
watch at your own pace
Hands-On Labs will give you the
opportunity to apply what you learned in
a practical setting you will also have
the chance to attend master classes
delivered by distinguished faculty from
IIT kanpur one of the India's primary
technical Institutes
the curriculum has been carefully
crafted to cover all the critical topics
in data science you will learn Python
Programming machine learning natural
language processing that is NLP and data
visualization
these topics are essential for
successful career in data science
The Learning Experience will be enhanced
to Hands-On Labs industrial relevant
projects that provide practical
real-world applications of the concepts
you learn upon completion of this course
you will receive a program completion
certificate from E and ICT Academy at
IIT Khan this certificate carries weight
and can add credibility to your resume
helping you stand out on the potential
employers now coming to the fifth course
that you can opt for after graduation
post graduate program in cloud computing
the postgraduate program in cloud
computing is a comprehensive course
designed to help you become an expert in
cloud computing Technologies such as
Azure AWS and gcp this program created
in collaboration with Caltech ctme
focuses on teaching you important
architectural principles and developing
the skills needed to excel in the field
of cloud computing by enrolling in this
program you will gain in-depth knowledge
and hands-on experience in designing
planning and scaling Cloud
implementations the course covers
essential skills required to design and
deploy applications that are dynamically
scalable and reliable on three major
Cloud platforms Microsoft Azure Amazon
web services and Google Cloud platform
that is gcp this course includes live
virtual classes led by industry experts
Hands-On projects and integrated labs to
enhance your learning experience so
these were some computer courses that
anybody can opt for after graduation so
take the next step explore our available
courses and embark on a journey of
continuous learning and success in the
world of computers now before we end
this video let's take a minute to hear
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers
after working two years as a developer I
was able to change my domain to cyber
security within my company and recently
I've joined a new organization with a 55
salary hike I decided to go with the
advanced executive program in cyber
security from triple it Bangalore
offered by simply learn while doing the
course I switched to the role of sock
Analyst at TCS I was able to do so
because of the skill sets that I have
acquired in the course there were a lot
of Hands-On projects all the important
topics were covered and the overall cost
really helped me a lot I'm glad that I
discovered my passion and took steps to
achieve it alright guys with that we
have come to the end of this video If
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up I hope it really helped you
all thanks for watching stay safe and
keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign